Voiceover:We've seen that
a function maps elements
from its domain.
If you give it an element in its domain
it will then map it to
an element in its range.
So for example,
if this is the domain.
Let me do this in this orange color.
If this is the domain of a function
and let me just pick out
some random elements right over here.
So let's say that this is one.
This is negative one.
This is seven.
And this is pi.
Let's say these are all members
of the domain of f.
And let's say that f and let's say
that this right over here is the range.
So this is right over here is the range.
And so let's say that f of one, f of one.
So if you input one into the function,
the function maps one to
the number negative three.
And let's say it maps
the number negative one
So f of negative one is equal to,
is equal to seven.
And let's say that f of seven,
f of seven is equal to 10.
But let's says that f of pi
is also equal to 10.
So this is the function map.
Again this is a legitimate function.
Remember in order to be a function
for any input it has to map it to a unique
it needs to map it to only one output.
This wouldn't be a function
if it did something like this.
If you input pi instead of
saying you're gonna get 10
instead of saying that
f of pi is equal to 10.
This is clearly a function.
You're mapping from pi to 10.
For the input pi you know
you're gonna get the output 10.
But if you were doing some type
of a relationship where you said oh well
if you put in a pi sometimes it's a 10
and sometimes it's an 11.
Now this would not be a function
cause you're mapping pi
to two different values right over here.
So that's not allowed if you're thinking
about a function.
For any input you have
to map it to only one,
only one output.
Now you could have two inputs
that map to the same output
because this is predictable.
You know that f of seven is 10
and you know that f of pi is 10.
Well what I wanna do is now think about
when does a function not
when it is not invertible?
We've already seen that the inverse
of a function should map
between an element of its range
and the corresponding
element in the domain.
So the inverse of f should map three,
negative three to one.
So f inverse.
So because because f of one, f of one.
Actually let me write it this way.
Actually I'll just write it.
Because f of one was
equal to negative three
f inverse, f inverse of negative three.
And the inverse function
is also a function.
So it has to have the same
properties of a function.
It should map to only one thing.
F inverse of negative three
is going to be equal to one.
F inverse of seven is going
to be equal to negative one.
F inverse, this is f
inverse right over here.
But now we have something
strange happening
if we think about let me write this down.
F inverse of seven is
equal to negative one.
That makes sense because we already knew
that f of f of negative
one is equal to seven.
But now something interesting
happens over here.
What would f inverse of 10 be?
Well f inverse of 10
if I'm trying to map it 10
there's two elements of the domain
that when I applied the function
got us to 10 in the range.
So if you're taking, if you're trying
to see whether f is invertible
then the inverse function
should map this element
to only one element of the domain.
But its mapping it to two
elements of the domain.
So is this equal to seven
or is this equal to pi?
And because the inverse
mapping can't be done
where you only map it with a unique thing
this function is not invertible.
This is not not invertible.
The inverse mapping, the inverse mapping
from the range to the domain
the inverse relationship
is not a function.
It does not it can't take
an element in our range
and map it to a unique
element to the domain.
For 10 we don't know.
Does that map to pi or
does that map to seven?
So this function f is a function.
For any member of its
domain it goes to a unique
it goes to its a very well
defined element in the range.
But the other way around isn't true.
For the inverse function
for any element in this set
it doesn't go to only
one element in that set.
This 10 could be mapped
to either pi or seven
so f inverse so another way
to think about this is
not an invertible f.
F is not invertible.
F is a function but the inverse
mapping is not a function
so we do not so we would say
that f is not invertible.